[THEME MUSIC]
SPEAKER: Good morning.
Please welcome Jack Lo.
JACK LO: Good morning,
everyone, and welcome to Next.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
I hope you all
enjoyed the keynotes.
As you heard, we've been
making a tremendous amount
of investment here
at Google to try
to help enterprises
come to the Cloud
and address your most critical,
most important business
challenges.
The keynotes were
packed, as we all know.
There are a lot of people
still trickling in.
Unfortunately, I'll have to
go through this a little bit
quicker so we'll get
you back on schedule
for all-important lunchtime.
But again, my name is Jack.
And I have the privilege and
the honor to speak about a topic
that I'm personally
very passionate about--
namely, how to help
enterprises bring together
your on-prem environments
with Google Cloud.
So as you heard in
the keynotes, we
believe that there is this
nirvana ahead of building
cloud-native applications.
And in fact, at Google,
over the past two decades
we've been building applications
that support billions of users.
In fact, there are
eight applications
ranging from Search and
YouTube, Gmail, et cetera,
that actually have taught
us the value of building
cloud-native applications.
Now, as we've moved
to public cloud,
we do believe that
this is ultimately
the end state that everyone
should be striving for.
When you actually build
applications in this style,
not only do you have the
ability to have importable,
but as you containerize
applications,
you take the benefits of
operational efficiencies.
You can actually
decouple applications
from operating system upgrades.
You can help your developers
be more efficient.
Often times, you're breaking
them into micro services
so individual teams can
work separately and upgrade
on their own cadence
rather than having
to coordinate a large monolith.
And in fact, these,
basically, are
some of the reasons that
this model, by increasing
your operational efficiency
and helping your agility,
this is really what drives
a lot of new directions
in Cloud and in
software development.
But as much as we want to
go up to that direction,
the reality is that the
majority of applications
today are down in
what we would consider
this lower-left quadrant.
They're sitting on-prem.
They're classic applications,
large monoliths, not easy
to upgrade, not easy
to modify, sometimes
difficult to maintain.
And so the question
is, what do we actually
do to address
these applications?
Ultimately, we want to
take these workloads
and try to find a way to
get to the upper right.
Unfortunately, that's just
not so straightforward.
You can have a whole
host of reasons
why your applications
might be difficult to move
to a new development model, or
even a new deployment model.
A wholesale migration like this
may seem extremely daunting
for most enterprises.
You know, you might say,
well, I'm a risk taker,
or I actually believe
in the future.
And so I'm going to
try to rip and replace.
This is one term that
oftentimes people use to say,
essentially I'm
going to start over.
I actually have an
important application.
I'm going to re-architect it.
I'm going to
rewrite it so that I
can get these
opportunities that come
with the cloud-native
application
in the public cloud.
But given the practical
challenges and complexities
with such an approach,
this is not the path
that most of the
time you'll take.
So let's look at a few more
incremental journeys to get
to this upper right nirvana.
So lift and shift,
you've probably all
heard about this
approach where we're
taking existing applications
and largely moving
them as-is to the public cloud.
Sometimes this ends up being
the most pragmatic approach.
And the reasons might be
because the applications are
coming from a third party ISV.
You may not have source code.
So it's not easy for you to
rewrite them or re-architect
them in a modern way.
Or perhaps you actually
do have the source code,
but these are applications
that were written
by developers many, many
years ago, most of whom
may not even be at
the company anymore.
Or they're a little bit
brittle and fragile.
So you're worried about
actually can you actually make
substantial changes because
the application's working
just fine today.
So in these cases,
moving to a public cloud
can still bring you benefits.
The question is,
how do you actually
make that migration
smooth and easy?
And later on in this talk,
I'll describe a few ways we've
been doing that here at Google.
But even if you just move
the application as is,
the migration to
public cloud can still
bring you a lot of benefits.
For example, you might be
running into a situation
where you have to upgrade
your physical infrastructure,
or turning down
your data centers,
and you have to make
a decision anyway
about where you're going
to run your workloads.
At this point, if you move
the applications to GCP,
you can still get the
benefits of efficiency
because now you don't have
to worry about managing
the physical infrastructure.
With capabilities like our live
migration and Google Compute
Engine, we handle the
upgrades of the servers
and the low-level
software on the machines
while the applications
continue to run.
One great example
of this recently
was the processor
vulnerabilities, Spectre
and Meltdown.
These were the largest
security vulnerabilities that
had been discovered in decades.
We were able, on
Google Cloud, to be
able to keep your applications
and workloads continually
running without actually having
to disrupt the applications
and make those patches to
the underlying software.
That's something that
reduces an operational burden
from your staff.
Now, beyond lift
and shift, you might
say, well, for some
of my workloads,
I can take it one incremental
step further, what
you might term as
lift and modernize,
or lift and re-platform.
And so what we mean by this
approach or this journey
is to take the step of,
say, a workload that's
running on-premises and then
moving it to a managed service.
So a great example of this might
be a database where you can now
move it from an on-premise
database to Cloud SQL,
or take your on-premise
Redis instance
and move it to
Cloud Memory Store.
With this path,
with this journey,
you no longer have to
manage the service itself.
That's handled by Google.
And it allows you to just
move your application
without any code changes.
Again, a slightly
lower-friction migration path
that's available to you to help
you on your journey to Cloud
Native.
Alternately, there
is another direction
which is to improve
first and then move.
And by this what we mean
is thinking about some
of the applications
that you have today
and deciding to take that step
and start to containerize them.
So separate the application
from the operating system,
as mentioned in the
keynotes, using Kubernetes
to start to orchestrate these
containers and the deployment
and management of
these applications.
Most IT organizations
have already
been adopting Kubernetes
for at least some
of the applications
and services.
And then once you've learned
the technology, learned
the deployment practices,
it becomes much easier
to take that next step
to move to the cloud.
Now, I'll mention that
yet another journey here,
in addition to lift and shift,
lift and improve, improve
and move, is build and connect.
So this is a little bit more
about an architecture style
rather than a form of migration.
And what I mean
by architecture is
some of your
complex applications
and services may have
many, many components.
Some of that are going
to stay on premises.
Some of that will be
running on the cloud.
And in this kind of an
environment or architecture,
you'd be looking at how
to use things like Apigee
and developing API
gateways to connect
that various components
of your system
that span multiple locations.
I'll talk briefly about
this later in the talk.
But at this point, the
thing that comes through
if you look at
all these journeys
is that it's a complex
path to get to the cloud.
It can certainly
be very daunting.
Most of you live in a very
diverse, heterogeneous world,
where you have applications that
are these shrink-wrapped apps.
Some of them you've
developed in-house,
others might be SaaS apps.
And then on top
of that, you have
lots of different data
centers and environments, some
that you own, some that may be
in a managed service provider,
some of that are in the cloud.
And you may be using
multiple clouds.
At Google, we recognize that
enterprises are complex.
And while we have a path that
we think is the right direction
to take, ultimately we want
to meet you where you are.
It's important to
let you run what
you want where you want
to satisfy your business
objectives.
So how do you get started?
I think an important
thing to think about
is, what are your goals?
Are you trying to
move everything
as quickly as you
can to the cloud?
Or do you want to take a
more incremental approach?
As we meet with customers,
oftentimes what people look at
is, what are some of the easiest
applications to move first?
So pick some of your
test dev applications.
But also start planning
an architecture that
allows you to move your more
complex workloads eventually,
so breaking it up
into waves and phases.
Part of the effort here is
also around understanding
first discovering what
applications you have.
How can you assess whether these
are good applications to move?
Do the planning and then
finally do the migration.
And then once you've
migrated them, optimize them.
So there are multiple sessions
here at the conference
where people go into more
detail about the programs that
are available through
partners, through PSO,
to help you with this
full migration process.
But now that we've talked
about some approaches
at a per-application
level, let's
take a step back and think
about the holistic picture.
In the keynote, [? Urs ?]
described the notion of hybrid.
And so ultimately, what you need
to have is the infrastructure
and framework to think
about how you manage
a diverse set of applications
across a diverse set
of locations.
And this is also a very critical
part of your cloud journey.
So what is hybrid?
You know, I think if you ask all
the people, probably 500 people
in the room, we might
get 400 different answers
of exactly what hybrid means.
It has a lot of different
interpretations.
But for the purposes
of this talk,
I think where I want to focus
on is just the recognition
that you do have
multiple locations
and multiple applications
and services that need to run
in a location that suits you.
And again, put simply, do
what you want where you want.
And what we found is that
this approach is something
that resonates with customers.
This is a survey of cloud
users by IDC recently.
And they found that 87%
of cloud users are hybrid.
More than half of them
have multiple kinds
of cloud deployments
in their organization.
And a large fraction of
them, 40%, are cloud-first.
So a lot of these trends are
very likely to be accelerating.
Practically speaking,
hybrid is a reality.
It's a state that exists now.
It's going to
continue to increase.
And it's going to be
a state that's going
to be here for years to come.
So how do you think about what
you want to do around hybrid?
One way is to break
it up into layers
in an overall architecture
starting from the network then
looking at the application layer
and then the management layer.
So lets look at each
of these in turn.
So networking obviously
is the underpinnings.
And in a sec, I will go into
some examples of how you might
build your hybrid network.
At the application
layer, this is
where there is a
lot of flexibility,
a lot of technology, a lot
of opportunity leveraging
the latest technologies like
containers and serverless.
As we heard in the
keynotes this morning,
the cloud services
platform and GKE on-prem
are examples of how you
actually build your applications
and services and spread across
your hybrid infrastructure.
And then on the highest layer,
thinking about management,
so lets go through a
couple of these starting
here, so networking.
So with networking Google
Cloud, one important step
in providing a
hybrid infrastructure
is figuring out how to
connect your on-premise data
center with Google Cloud.
So the Virtual
Private Cloud, or VPC,
is a way to actually create
an isolated network in GCP
for your own private access.
It allows you to make GCP
look like your own network.
But when you connect it
to your own data center,
then it becomes
simply an extension
of your on-premises footprint.
But it's more than just
connecting a single data center
to one GCP region.
A single VPC can actually
span multiple regions
across the globe
without having to go out
onto the public internet.
So why is that important?
Well, for several reasons.
One, from that single
on-premise data center
you've now been able to connect
to all of the Google regions.
You don't actually
have to set up
a separate different connection
from your data center
to each of the regions that
you want to operate in.
Secondly, it gives you much
lower and more predictable
latencies when you
actually have to connect
across these regions,
especially for those services
that you have that are large
scale, global services,
because you don't have to go
out into the public internet.
And then finally,
having a global VPC
really helps you in
terms of manageability
because you can now
have a single VPC
policy that spans this network.
And from a management
standpoint,
that simplifies your problem.
So let's say you actually
wanted to take advantage
of these technologies.
What are some of the
steps that you would take?
So there are three
different options
to connect your
data center to GCP.
The first is to use a more
traditional VPN-like approach.
So with Cloud VPN, you
connect your GCP project
to an on-premise VPN gateway.
And then now you can
encrypt data in transit.
For some customers,
your requirements
might be more substantial.
And so you could choose to go
down the dedicated interconnect
route.
With dedicated interconnect,
you bring your network
and you meet it at one of our
dedicated interconnect points
of presence.
We have more than 70 dedicated
POPs across worldwide
and are continuing
to add to them.
With each of these
interconnect points,
you can get increments of 10
gigabits per second bandwidth.
But for some
customers, perhaps you
don't have such demanding
networking needs.
And that's why we have
a third option, which
is called partner interconnect.
This might be a case where
you're not really close to,
or your data centers aren't,
sufficiently close to one
of our Points of Presence.
And so what you do is you
actually work with a partner.
The partner has a peering
location with GCP.
And then you peer
with a partner.
This is a turnkey solution
integrated into the console.
And it allows you to have a
more flexible set of networking
options, up to 10 gigabits per
second per VLAN all the way
down to 50 megabits per second.
So that provides the
basic infrastructure
that you need for a
hybrid architecture.
Moving up the stack to
the application layer,
there are many other talks
at the conference where
people go into detail here.
We could spend hours
talking about what
you wouldn't want to build
for hybrid applications.
I think here I just
want to highlight
a few of the basic principles,
namely around portability,
abstraction, and automation.
So the ideas here are you want
to have a set of designs that
allow services and
components to interoperate
in a meaningful way,
and so standardizing
on open source components,
open APIs are a key part of it.
And then once you
do this, you want
to be able to automate and
be able to manage at scale.
And then finally moving up
to the management layer,
here you can choose to take
a variety of approaches
depending on what you
may have standardized
in your environment and
what you may decide you
want to actually change
in your environment.
Basically, it's kind of
your appetite for change.
So at the management layer,
one of the most critical pieces
of your stack is
around monitoring.
So you need to
have a way to have
ongoing monitoring of the
health of your applications
and services.
And Stackdriver provides
a suite of tools that
give you operational awareness.
There's a set of tools
for logging and monitoring
the services that
are running inside
of, say, virtual
machines or running
in terms of other containers.
And it doesn't matter
where they're running.
They can be on GCP.
They can be running on-premise.
They can be running elsewhere.
And this is one way to kind
of unify your management
of your workloads.
A second path is Kubernetes.
As it was announced this
morning, with GKE on-prem,
we now have the ability to have
a single controlled experience
that manages across the
cloud and on premises.
So no matter where you run
them, on your data centers
or in the cloud, you can
have a consistent experience.
And the third one is maybe
aimed at some of you who might
have a VMware environment.
So you might have lots of
tools and practices built up
around your VMware
infrastructure.
We have been
partnering with VMware
to build a plugin to fit
into that set of tools.
So we recently,
last week, announced
that we've been working
together on a plugin
for vRealize automation
and vRealize orchestrator.
So for those of you who aren't
familiar with this environment,
essentially what some
customers have done
is created a portal or sort
of their own private cloud.
And they create blueprints.
This is one of the more common
use cases for these tools
where you've identified
if some end user wants
to actually create
an application,
you click on a blueprint.
It automatically
deploys resources.
Now, for those people
who are using VRO or VRA,
the natural extension is to be
able to back those resources
with resources in GCP.
And so this plugin
allows you to get
some of the benefits of
cloud while continuing
to use your existing
management infrastructure.
So now you can use a blueprint.
The blueprint actually
creates virtual machines
in Google Compute Engine.
And now those workloads
can take advantage
of things like basically
lower cost compute--
because you have
the various forms
of discounts like sustained use
or community use discounts--
the custom machine types.
And this environment is
now running and using
resources in the cloud,
even though you're
using your existing on-premises
management infrastructure.
So this plug-in is
in EAP right now.
If you're interested
in taking a look,
there's a sign up
for you to take part.
OK, folks.
A second to take a picture.
All right.
So we've talked a little
bit about various journeys
that you would take
for applications
to get to the cloud.
We've talked a little bit
about a hybrid architecture
that you might want
to think about when
you're coming in the cloud.
But you still have
to figure out how
you can move those actual
workloads and that data
as quickly as possible.
So if you're going
down this path,
what are some of the
biggest challenges
you're going to run into?
A recent survey showed that
most migration projects,
unfortunately, aren't
super successful.
About 94% of them
run into delays.
They're over budget.
We've often heard
even of cases where
people have moved
workloads to the cloud only
to move them back because of
something they didn't realize,
something they didn't
plan for properly.
Why is this hard?
Well, a lot of organizations
have not just hundreds
but maybe thousands of
workloads and applications
that they need to move.
So how do you handle the scale?
How do you figure out
which applications to move,
what the dependencies are?
It's pretty daunting,
not to mention the fact
that organizationally,
you will have
different owners of
these applications
and you may need to get their
approval in the migration
process.
Another area of
complexity is they
come from different sources.
Many of them could be running
in virtual machines on VMware.
They could be
running on physical.
Some of them could
be in another cloud
and you want to
move them to GCP.
Of course, we have
also complexity.
Your most mission-critical
workload--
say it's in SAP or
in Oracle database--
these are applications
that are business critical.
You do want to take advantage
of moving them to the cloud.
But the problem is, you
can't take any business risk
and you don't even want
to take any downtime,
or at least keep that downtime
to an absolute minimum.
So those concerns lead
into this question of risk.
How can you actually
prepare yourself and test?
And is there a way
that you can make sure
that it's highly likely
that workloads succeed when
you move them, but in the worst
case, if things don't go well,
you can roll back?
Fortunately, we came
across a partner
that we'd been working with
for a while called Velostrata.
And we recently announced an
acquisition about a month ago
that closed.
They were already a partner
helping with migrations
to Google Cloud.
But we found that it's a very
complementary team, technology,
and product.
And really what they
are enabling us to do
is provide an enterprise-grade
purpose-built solution
for helping accelerate the
migrations of workloads to GCP.
Not only can they move from
on-premises to Google Cloud,
but you can also
move from AWS to GCP.
So this technology
and this product
is a real enabler to reducing
the friction involved
in these complex migrations.
One of the key
capabilities is that it
allows you to move your
workloads very quickly,
oftentimes with less than
10 minutes of downtime.
And that's pretty amazing.
If you think about how you want
to actually reduce the impact
and reduce the friction
of a migration,
if you can reduce that downtime,
this is a critical advantage.
So the typical migration,
what will happen
is you'll have a bunch of
data, the disks associated
with your VMs, and you need
to copy that up to the cloud
before you can actually migrate.
And if it's a large VM with,
say, a terabyte virtual disk,
that's going to take some time.
That could take hours.
Now you multiply
that by hundreds
of workloads or
thousands, and you can see
how long this process can take.
The key insight from
the Velostrata team
was to look at how you
decouple compute from storage.
And so the idea is that actually
you can stream the storage.
So essentially what happens
is you take a short downtime
period at the beginning.
And you start bringing over
the most critical pieces
of the storage.
And there's a lot of
intelligence and WAN
optimization in this
technology that allows
you to start that process.
And then once you've moved
those critical pieces,
you can start running
your workload in the cloud
while the rest of the data gets
migrated in the background.
You know, they say a picture
is worth a thousand words.
So let's take a
look at this graph.
What it shows here is--
this is from a customer example.
This is showing
time on the x-axis.
And y is both the number
of VMs that are running--
sorry, that have been
moved to the cloud--
as well as in green the amount
of data that's been migrating.
So this customer chose
to make two-week sprints
to actually do the migration.
And you can see that
there's a step function.
In the first week
what they would do--
just to kind of blow into
one of these sprints--
they did some discovery
planning, so picking up,
say, 75 VMs that they
actually want to migrate.
So figure out which ones they
are, kind of plan internally
how they would move them,
actual scheduling the migration.
And then in the second week,
do the actual migration.
Now, what you can see
in this blown-up zoom
is that most of the VMs
were moved and running
in the cloud in hours.
Meanwhile, the data is
streaming in the background.
And in fact, it took about
three days for all the data
to get there.
But in this time,
the customer was
able to actually start running
these applications again
and not impact their business.
And when you think
about the amount of time
you have to do
migrations, this means
you can easily do a migration
of a large number of workloads
over a weekend
rather than trying
to look at many, many days
of moving a lot of data.
So why is this important?
Well, one, minimizing
downtime and then taking
advantage of other
capabilities in the tool
set to be able to validate
and increase the confidence
that your workloads
are successful.
As I mentioned earlier,
oftentimes less than 10 minutes
and you're up and running.
You save a lot of manpower.
You accelerate the
process of migration.
And this actually greatly
increases the likelihood
that a migration project will
be successful because you
can stay under budget.
But earlier I mentioned
one of the challenges that
was around risk and complexity.
What this technology also
allows you to do is roll back.
Unfortunately, there's a
conflicting deep dive session
right now going on about
the Velostrata technology.
So hopefully you can see
a video or look at some
of the collateral online.
But there's also the
ability to roll back
because while we're streaming
the data to the cloud,
there's still data for that
virtual machine running
on premises.
And if you find,
for some reason,
that maybe you forgot to move
a workload that it depends on
or you have some
other challenge,
you always have the
ability to move back.
And that safety net,
that insurance policy,
is very valuable when it
comes to actually doing
these large-scale migrations.
And ultimately, now by getting
these migrations to happen,
you can get to ramp up your
cloud usage much more quickly.
Now, in addition to migrating
your virtual machines,
you may actually also
have a lot of data
that needs to be migrated.
The data transfer
appliance is one solution
that's available to
help take, if you have,
say, hundreds of
terabytes of data
that you need to move
to the cloud in addition
to your virtual
machines, you just
can't afford to actually
move all that data.
This is not necessarily so
much for the virtual machines
in the Velostrata
case, but it could
be because you have
some data warehouse
or other large amounts
of data that you
need to be able to use
while you're in the cloud.
So the transfer appliance
comes in 2U and 4U form
factors with 100 terabyte
and 480 terabyte versions.
The larger one can handle
up to roughly about
a petabyte of data compressed.
Basically, it's as simple
as going to the console,
requesting a transfer appliance.
You get it.
You rack it.
You fill it up with data
and then ship it back to us.
Basically, this is a solution
where you can actually
have it sit in the
data center for a while
and then bring it
back to Google Cloud.
So now that we've
talked a little bit
about some of the
migration challenges
and some of the solutions
that are available,
I wanted to bring
one of our customers
from Cardinal Health,
Jon Latshaw, who
is the Vice President of
Cloud Services at Cardinal,
and have him talk a little
bit about the company and some
of the work they've
been doing with Google.
Jon?
JON LATSHAW: Thanks
for having me.
JACK LO: So Jon, can you
first tell the audience
and tell us a little bit
about Cardinal Health, what
you guys do?
JON LATSHAW: We do
a lot of things.
But in summary, we try to make
health care more efficient
and cost effective.
We're a Fortune 15 company
with about $130 billion
in revenue, about 700 sites,
and a lot of applications,
not to be too specific.
JACK LO: Yeah.
So--
JON LATSHAW: One other
point, if any of you
have had the misfortune
to be in a hospital
or need to get a prescription
for some sort of illness,
you've probably
used our services
just going to a CVS or
some sort of hospital.
JACK LO: One of
the things when I
was visiting you guys
recently, hearing the stories
about the kind of on-demand
nature of the business
you're in, like someone
ordering something today
for a patient that
has a procedure
tomorrow, and critical services
that you have to deliver
to make sure that happens.
JON LATSHAW: It's hard to
plan emergencies, yeah.
JACK LO: So can you
talk a little bit
about what prompted Cardinal's
migration to the cloud?
JON LATSHAW: Yeah.
In a nutshell, it's
speed and efficiency.
So we-- our business
is hard to predict.
Wouldn't think that from
if you look at health care.
But it's actually a large
component of our business
is pharmaceutical distribution,
so where drugs need to be,
where generics might launch.
And so a lot of that requires
us to turn on a dime.
And with traditional
infrastructure,
it's just hard to do,
whereas, conversely, with GCP,
I can spin up, spin down,
all at a moment's notice.
And then although we have
a $130 billion in revenue,
we actually run on
grocery store margins.
So every penny counts.
So we've found that running
in the cloud, if you do it
the right way, can
be considerably more
cost-effective than
doing it ourselves.
JACK LO: So with that in mind,
I mean, can you talk about some
of the best practices, or
perhaps lessons learned
that you guys have experienced?
JON LATSHAW: Yeah.
To kind of go back a little
bit in your presentation,
if you haven't heard of
Velostrata, go check it out.
It's the real deal.
We were one of their
first customers.
Makes a tremendous difference
if you're doing any kind of lift
and shift or lift and
lately optimize migrations,
there's a lot of
that we're doing.
And it really works
as advertised.
It sounded a lot like magic to
me when they first pitched it.
And they've proven to be a
great partner and it works.
So on that, we're about a
third of the way through,
and we've learned
a lot of things.
There's one thing
that I would say--
the technology is not
the hardest part of this.
So while it is challenging
in some aspects,
don't worry about that so much.
What I would say is, get your
house in order while you're
contemplating moving.
Move some non-prod workloads.
But before you move
production, make
sure that your CMDB is
accurate and up to date.
We had a very complete CMDB.
We could go through and say
all the fields were filled out.
But when we wanted to gain
intelligence about our systems,
like what systems were part
of a business process, what
applications needed to talk
to what applications on what
ports, it wasn't
reliable because we never
had to use it like that.
So spend some time getting
that stuff in order.
And be sure you can answer
the right questions about what
needs to talk to what.
I would say be friends
with your finance people.
This change is going
to have a ripple effect
of substantial changes
through the finance team.
They need to be prepared
for direct chargebacks.
You don't have to do
direct chargebacks.
We chose to.
It drives the right behavior.
But it is a massive
adjustment for them.
Lastly, partner up.
Maybe buy your CSO bottle
of their favorite beverage
repeatedly.
Security folks by their
nature are extremely cautious.
Google has an enormous
emphasis on security.
But it's not only
their responsibility.
It's a joint responsibility.
And we've spent a lot of
time on bringing the security
folks along, getting our CSO on
board, getting an endorsement.
So that's kind of in a nutshell.
If I had it to do over again,
I would spend more time upfront
on those things and less time
worrying about the technology.
JACK LO: Great.
So can you also
talk a little bit
about your experience with
Google Cloud, specifically?
What has kind of stood
out with that partnership?
JON LATSHAW: A couple
of things there.
One, they've been
a great partner.
So their product teams
have been very curious.
We've gotten access to that.
So for those that are
kind of just dipping
the toe in the water,
if you've had experience
with on-premise companies
like, I don't know,
a database company
that begins with an O
or something like
that, and you say,
hey, it'd be great to have this
feature in your next release,
maybe in a year, two
years it might come out.
We've had the experience of
working with our product teams
to say, hey, on your API
gateway, we would like this.
And they're like, OK, cool.
And literally six weeks
later, we have that feature.
So they've been extremely
responsive, extremely
curious on what it takes
for us to move to the Cloud.
And it's not an
unselfish investment.
I mean, we're a lot like
every other Fortune 500.
We have the widest variety
of systems you can imagine.
And if Google invests
in making us successful,
then that just paves the
way for everyone else.
I've found their
infrastructure, their network
to be fast and reliable, more
so than other cloud providers
we've looked at.
Live migration's a
big feature for us.
We did some things
internally that are
kind of unnatural
acts, but it was
to save on licensing fees
for some WebSphere products
where we would create a VM that
had two CPUs but 48 gig of RAM.
And we did that because we
wanted to save on licensing.
So in some cases, we're
going to unwind that
and we're going to do it
the right way in the cloud.
Some cases, we can't.
And so their custom machine
size gives us that flexibility
to do that instead of
kind of the t-shirt sizing
that other cloud providers have.
JACK LO: Great.
Well, thank you so much, Jon.
JON LATSHAW: Thank you.
JACK LO: Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
It's great to have
the opportunity
of fantastic customers
like Jon and his team,
and look forward
to collaborating
further on their continued
journey into the cloud.
So before I wrap up here,
I want to just highlight
a number of sessions.
There is actually
probably many other ones
that are related to
the topics that we've
talked about where you can
get a little bit deeper.
There are some customers
who have also-- we
can talk about their
experiences moving to GCP.
Or if you want to look at
other different technologies
and products that have
done migrations to Cloud,
here's a few sessions.
And as I mentioned earlier,
unfortunately that 112 session
is going on right now.
So I just want to leave you all
with a few important takeaways.
I think what I would try to do
is paint the journeys that you
might want to take.
And it's really
important to recognize
that this modernization
of IT is important.
There's a great opportunity
here to improve efficiencies
and help you accelerate
your business,
rather than having IT
infrastructure just
be a lot about cost.
But ultimately, Google is
here to meet you where you we.
Have a vision for where we
want it to take everyone.
But along the way, everyone
might have a slightly different
journey.
Second is hybrid is
just the reality.
It is going to
require rethinking
a little bit about
your architecture
from a network to a management
to an application standpoint,
but it's important to
have a vision for where
you want to go because this
is a reality that's here
for many, many years ahead.
And then finally,
the journey is long.
It's complex.
But we're here to
support you, whether it's
through PSO, through the
many partners we have here
at the conference, from
the engineering teams,
from the customer teams.
We're here to help
you be successful.
There's a lot of resources
and tools and guides.
And so please reach out if you
need help with your migration.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[THEME MUSIC]